hey guys welcome to skyj i'm sitting on
a big big sack i came downstairs because
like i said in my previous video you
guys have been yelling at me because
you're so sick of my white wall but
guess what i love my white wall
[Music]
thank you guys so much for all of your
questions it's kind of funny because a
lot of you keep tweeting me saying
justine why haven't you posted any new
videos i've noticed that some of you
have been unsubscribed for my channel
thank you i don't know why i'm gonna
have to ask you to not come down here
because i'm making a video
somebody just asked me what happened to
my furby did i kill him
i did oh
okay now back to my questions uh what
happened to my furby um ryan did not
kill my furby he's actually sitting
inside of a laundry basket because i
tried to keep him away from light and
people with movement because it kept
making all these annoying sounds and i
was like shut up furby shut up yammy
wants to know what my favorite place for
vacation or business trip has been
definitely my favorite vacation spot has
been bora bora it was kind of unlike
anything i've ever experienced it was
pretty much like a living dead island
video game a lot less zombies
actually no zombies there were no
zombies there so that's good this doll
1031 is asking what my most memorable
high school experience was that would
have to be
when i graduated and didn't have to
return to high school anymore to be
completely honest with you i don't
actually even remember my high school
graduation at all i really don't
remember much about high school at all
except i didn't really like it played a
lot of video games i was kind of
i was really cool i had so many friends
and
next question why does the pick for your
imac unboxing video look like you're
throwing up in the box you know friend i
really don't know so judge for yourself
but i really wasn't i was just excited i
was like
christian clements do you like pooping
moving right along next question please
apple nintendo or android
oh come on though come on apple ornament
i can't well that's really hard i mean
i'd have to choose apple android i could
definitely do without nintendo i mean i
wouldn't want to do without then i'm
gonna have to do what i have to do
sorry
miley says i j do you ever look back to
your old youtube videos so what will you
say about yourself well actually i have
looked back at some of my old videos and
i'm really thinking what the what kind
of songs do i have my iphone or ipod
pretty much the only songs that i have
on my phone or by ellie goulding because
i love her i even have a skrillex song
because she
made a little cameo in summit have i
read sushi and do i like it i kind of do
like sushi but the past few times that
i've had sushi not good experiences well
just go back to what was his name
christian clements question and say no i
do not so no sushi for me if you were a
boy for one day what would you do i will
go and pee on
everything why do i play unfair mario if
it really annoys me i really only enjoy
it when i get to that last little flag
and i'm like yes the victory is
mine
it's a very very stressful game everyone
is asking if i feel down at times when i
read bad stuff about me on the internet
if yes how do i deal with it it is kind
of a hard thing to deal with because
these people who may see like 10 or 15
second clips of me and instantly judge
that's pretty much normal human behavior
i at times judge people and i don't even
know them so i try to think back to how
that makes me feel it's a terrible
feeling truthfully it has kind of made
me a better person because i know how it
feels to be judged so i try not to judge
other people so i'm an extremely
accepting person and i love everyone so
if you've got something bad to say about
me
it's probably not true at all so
feel free to say whatever you want
sequence nope i've ever pulled up
somewhere and something was missing yes
i have the ceiling was in fact freaking
missing hold up to the theme massively
missing
not sure what that is cybertone is
asking how many channels do i have here
and do i have an assistance to keep
track of them all i actually don't which
is probably the reason that i'm gonna
probably get rid of my reviews channel
i'd much rather focus on my main channel
and kind of creating good content for
you guys as opposed to trying to fill up
all these channels with videos i still
shoot and edit all of my own stuff which
oh my god when people find that out
they're like you're crazy you're insane
get an editor i've tried people just
don't edit the way that i want things to
be edited so by the time i explained to
somebody what i want them to edit i
could have just edited myself and posted
it post posted it i love you guys thanks
so much for all of your questions be
sure to leave all of your questions in
the comments below you can tweet them to
me you can do whatever it is that you do
be sure to like this video if you liked
it if you didn't like it you can click
like and i won't tell anybody don't
forget to subscribe and i will see you
guys in the next video here on my
idrestone channel
bye
[Music]